su redneck hay noticias internacionales
en ningun momento me paso la chica
situación económica de este país que él
llegará a esto es la damila de ayer
en la zona economica en francia las 24 horas ahi
Mila colección de indicadores de este país.
Mira a Santiago como celulares así
Es importante recordar algunos puntos que
para él la situación económica de un país
que finalmente es la Que Hay kanaan na
crisis política en la crisis económica hay
11 millones de habitantes y la
el pais mas pobre de america
Estado latino y del hemisferio occidental
para eliminar esa mirada es que tu
economía aquí del petróleo y en el tres por ciento
del muy bien a las habichuelas y al mio en
tierra negativa o antes de ella la sartén
También parece que no tiene un lazo.
reservar el 25% al ​​año y creer que salir
por cierto, las personas son sociales podridas
en los seis como en los tres millones de pobreza
fuerza extrema, los cuarteles eran los más
rápido así como disparamos años
o el miercoles
El apoyo de Silva a la hermana que no tienes
ojo es rey aquí está allá André
decir que él la mitad de su
habitantes a tomar las condiciones de
inseguridad alimentaria cronica
Congelados 2 mil bien este año fueron
perdido si entonces pequeño ejemplo de tarjeta si
él va por todo el mundo no sé organización
para la cooperación y económica
también conocidos como países centrales
rico decir que leyó eso Ale
Roseli y su anterior pandemia
concretamente trabajo que en 12 mil
ventilado Todo trabajo casa y tres yo
Entonces me convertí sólo en Sintra para cooperar en la
otro es este McQueen 2mil viene texto de
garantia de la chica 22 central
arroz molido en sus países miembros
cantame ni para lo mio en la copa ejemplo
elogiado como audio por convertirse en él
pasado cuando la gente siempre me decía
así que no es cierto solo cinco con un
tres por ciento entonces el mundo era
perder en los neumáticos Abrir cansado como si
trajo Alô 114 millones de discos
si no eres las letras recordadas que
está introduciendo Estados Unidos a
esta temporada la araña no me tiene ahora
eso es más yo por el segundo mes
consecutivos en Total Este es el top que
él siempre amó que no podía cubrir el
nuestro señor era como la mente única
gestionar gente entrar al arroz ya esta
fueron asaltados por aquellos que no pensaban
registrado en 2001 siempre informe
pequeño león con el ojo es su cinco cómo
acumula por ciento para el como si
aplicar fenómeno tengo diamante allí
varios aspectos a seriamente en la economía
acceso recuperándose rápidamente y el
le dieron mención en el envío de la carta a
radio por también en ese con nosotros
también contrario es uno terminar el otro
prepárate y allí antes y para la mente fue
economista y político quemarlos que él
es que la letra de la semana Así que míralos
este es el paciente los amigos
Enamorándome sé que fue en casa en alguna parte
de Oliveira uno por o menos pagado
muy siempre son inclusivos
aumentar los salarios para atraerla
personas y sobre esta base además de restaurantes
hoteles en educación
América mira señora el momento de suplicar
positivo y ahi mejor aqui ahi estas
previsiones para la economía europea también
ya la comisión europea ver su
proyecciones en la parte superior de ese producto
bruto interno tanto la unión europea
como va a crecer cuatro por sat
entonces 24 Cómo así cuando Dios mucho
mentiroso sí examen economía español la
más favorecido sin embargo bloquearlo
comunidad, él también es una preocupación allí
la inflación como si fuera un
aceleración i las variantes de corregir la
señora es
y la serpiente de Corsa por supuestamente haber
incertidumbre cara energía derivada
bailando a rascar en el vehiculo retrovisor
palanca están asociados con la variante
Vegeta que parece ser más
transmisibles que representan un peligro
en particular para detectar al instante
evacuado completamente la situación exterior
y la Unión Europea también siguiendo la
condiciones preocupantes que pasamos en el tiempo
ahi los indicadores como eran los
principales este se puede extender y antes
por atras miralo me controle corte
los inocentes son anchos y nazar despues
que show de la Reserva Federal en Sumaré
ciencias exactas que él economía allí para
well truck latinoamerica remix a uno
pareja Paulo se recuperó de las preguntas
que iba a tener mil y un artes animales
después de la publicación de la pieza, fue solo aprender cómo
así para que él vaya 50 Te ves así de dick y
nos vamos a africa mira esto de aqui
mira el look estadounidense promedio siempre
y este no es un nombre nacional
dietas que se introdujeron alrededor de
centrarse en este país África
y combatir el fenómeno de
hiperinflacion que ya es tuya y ahora luz
Tendría nombre nacional y lo entiendo Mira
que eran lanzas que no conozco en el pasado
La librería Simbal ahora presenta su propia
mal camino pero ese no es el impulso
al final del vivo si Léo está, no puedo
con dios llegué tarde y no me voy a ir
hogar de lo importante es que no sé
gracias a dios por sintonizar c
[Música]